there are high stakes meeting is getting
underway between the U.S and China after
the arrival of U.S treasury secretary
Janet Yellen in Beijing just this
morning you're looking at pictures the
visit comes of course at a time of
strained relations at best between the
two superpowers and Liz Palmer reports
now from Beijing
she'll have two days of high-level
meetings with Chinese officials a quick
trip meant to get the U.S China
relationship back onto a less hostile
footing but it is a tough assignment
this spring Xi Jinping accused America
of containment encirclement and
suppression basically trying to get in
the way of China's rise as a superpower
he's angry about a whole raft of U.S
tariffs on Chinese goods and the Biden
administration's restrictions on the
sale of advanced electronics to China on
the grounds of National Security in a
tit-for-tat move yesterday China
announced it would restrict the sale of
two metals that it mines and that are
essential to the manufacture of
microchips neither side is expected to
make significant concessions during
these meetings but at the very least
secretary Yellen will try to head off
further escalation
after all the U.S and China For Better
or For Worse are huge trading partners
and as the secretary herself has said
decoupling the two economies ending that
economic relationship would be
disastrous Nate
Elizabeth Palmer in Beijing thank you